in a
small village in Loudoun County and we
province China
the area is very well suited for rice
production so the rice is one of the
major crop for the village I farmed
nearly every day when I was a middle
school and high school student mostly in
the morning hours for rice farming we
don't have much machines to help
everything's pretty much done by hand
like a transplanting or that means we
basically put the rice seedlings into
the muddy field and weeding when the
rice grown up good so we have to remove
the weeds to help rice group better by
the time ready to harvest we have to go
there and cut them by hand then we
stretch them
okay the grain is also done by hand so
it's very physically demanding I
probably got interested in science
during my middle school and high school
years when I learned some more in
science subjects like physics chemistry
and also my living environment I would
say so also a factor I just don't want
to be like a rad farmer all the time as
I told you there was farming activities
is very physically demanding we don't
earn much all day I'd sooner want a
better life then you know the most of
religious had their bill I saw them I
want to change
as a profession the scientists is
certainly one of their profession at the
top we all respect
so we don't know much what scientists do
which probably is just just think just
thought or they are doing something very
important for the world so if you were
able to become a scientist then you are
somewhere probably very important based
on my personal experience I value
several things the first thing probably
was the dream that I had when I was
young I don't know why I just had that
dream when I was very young to be to be
a scientist I would say thinking big
probably is very important for young
people to have and another thing that I
also value that is your motivation how
much you motivated are to the things
that you do if you are highly motivated
and you really want to accomplish the
thing the goal that you set for yourself
and plus high walking or you can get
there where you you want
you